après le meilleur pâtissier le succès de
tous en cuisine cyril lignac s'embarque
dans une toute nouvelle aventure sur m6
et oui on n'arrête plus vous allez
pouvoir retrouver le chef dans une
émission intitulée mon gâteau est le
meilleur de france
au programme des gâteaux ont toujours un
jury d'experts et des amateurs de
pâtisseries ou quoi se régaler
accompagné de quatre jurés merouane
minecraft pp le match louise petitrenaud
et luana belmondo cyril lignac passionné
la france est à l'écouté les différentes
créations des candidats on vous emmène
en voyage
plus de 100 gâteau a goûté à travers
cette ville avignon nancy mc hong hao
crise de foie le gagnant aura le
privilège de pouvoir commercialiser ses
créations dans les boutiques lignac pour
voir le résultat
rendez-vous le 26 avril sur m6 alors mon
gâteau est le meilleur de france la
nouvelle émission qui débarque sur m6
j'y crois comme vous l'avez dit on est
au bord de l'indigestion encore m6 qui
nous refait un concept autour de moi je
n'en peux plus sur la digestion essayé
nous trouver des nouveaux concepts et
c'est nous nous faire des nouvelles
mécaniques je sais pas mais là on on
peut mais je suis franchement ça fait
beaucoup mais je pense que ça fait
beaucoup si au moins il avait changé si
ce n'était pas tourné en plateau tête se
rendent chez les personnes qui font les
gâteaux voir un peu le reste c'est ce
qu'ils vont faire
cette ville de france bah voilà bah non
c'est le but divine oui et piqué est
fort justement du succès qu'ils ont
connu cette saison avec le meilleur
pâtissier cyril lignac qui est là mais
la meilleure égérie pour ce type bien
sûr forcément ça va fonctionner mais je
vous cache pas que je peux pas regarder
si moi j'ai hâte de retrouver un gâteau
c'est rassurant c'est le gâteau de même
hissé le gâteau nos mamans soit ça peut
donner des idées assez pour s'appeler
d'une carte chouchou
[Applaudissements]
autant c'est très intéressant autant ces
lignes a et c les rides selignac a
accueilli les téléspectateurs qui y
viennent tous en cuisine
là se rend chez les gens c'est un peu la
barre est d'accord ils seront chez les
gens vous font faire des pâtisseries ya
une demande benjamin franchement si ma
femme m'ont dégoûté pas les autres il ya
plein de gens qui adorent et oui dans
les gâteaux mais je vais l'acheter mais
pas du tout mais les gens aiment bien
les gâteaux qu'ils ont avec moi il ya un
truc à un bémol
merouane chemakh pas me voir vraiment
j'ai vraiment du mal en plus il est
hyper l'en-but sa personne et à chaque
fois il me dérange pas si loin de bouder
pas mais ligne axa d'or et seront coup
voilà on en a jamais assez de l'ags
bayou vous ayez la raison moi j'ai envie
de prendre trois kilos à chaque fois je
vois le ballon allait devoir l'émission
ma cuisine c'est la meilleure angers ça
va être la suite en fait moi ma cuisine
c'est la meilleure moi ma cuisine c'est
non mais moi je veux vous voir ça comme
here
c'est lui je dis oui à la pétition oui à
la pâtisserie but c'est vraiment pas
important vraiment pas le problème c'est
qu'on avait alors pardon 1 francesca
mais on a dit ça on veux tu en voilà
maintenant ça va être du cyril lignac en
veut toujours là mais aussi de ses
émissions moi qui adore faire des
gâteaux
le problème c'est qu'on n'arrive pas
s'identifier c'est là qu'on n'arrive pas
à se dire on peut faire nous aussi la
même chose donc je suis infirmier pas
avec des bouchées pâtisserie oui mais
déjà écoulé
la monarchie l'arizona n'a pourtant
jamais donné